Hello Freak bitches.
I might have to spark up a joint fess
up.
So you just want real deep,
real quick.
I was hoping I was hoping would go that
way.
Do you want some you smoke the weed?
I could do it for the first time.
I'd be willing to try it ones.
Well I don't know if I want to give it
to you for the first time.
I don't want you to freak out.
You don't smoke pot at all.
The truth is I s I smoked pot once ever.
It was in first day of college,
but I never stopped.
So that's really just once.
Oh,
I understand.
So you smoked pot all the time.
So he did it once and you just kept
going.
I'd be willing to try it a second time
is what I'm saying.
I understand what you're saying or for
sure what hers,
like
what has life been like for Scott Adams
during this election?
You,
um,
came into the,
well,
you're obviously always well known for
being the creator of Dilbert,
but,
um,
along selection cycle,
all of a sudden there was,
I had,
you know,
people that are already in contact with,
they were saying,
you know,
Scott Adams is a trump supporter.
And I was like,
what Scott Adams,
the Dilbert guys,
a trump supporter.
Because you know,
everyone assumes you meet someone and
they're uh,
in the creative business,
you know,
you're in a creative business,
your,
you write a comic strip,
you would assume that you would be left
wing guy.
Like almost almost immediately.
Well,
I'm neither left nor right.
I'm sort of all over the place.
My,
my views didn't match,
you know,
either of the major candidates on
anything.
So you're a free thinker.
I like to think I'm right and everybody
else was wrong.
I would like that too.
I'm actually,
um,
my larger philosophical grounding is
that is informed by my experience,
says,
Hey,
I've noticed,
I'm not sure if he knew that.
No,
I didn't know you're a hypnotist.
So in my twenties,
I went to hypnosis school and became an
actual train certified hypnotist.
Wow.
And one of the things you learn as a
hypnotist is it,
the world is backwards to the way people
normally perceive it.
So normally you see the world as,
Hey,
you know,
90% of the time people are irrational
and doing rational things,
but 10% of the time we just go knots and
we do stupid things.
And it's because something happened.
This sparked,
right?
That's the normal view of the world.
The hypnotist view of the world is
opposite.
The hypnotist says that 90% of the time
we're a completely irrational and we're
just making rationalizations for why we
did things after the fact.
10% of the time we're rational.
But that's only when there's no
emotional content to the decision.
You know,
you're balancing a checkbook or
something,
you know,
trying to pick up,
the best route to someplace.
Um,
and so that's how I see the world.
And so when I look at either the trump
supporters or the Clinton supporters,
to me from the hypnotist perspective and
someone who's studied persuasion for
decades,
I used it in my writing.
Um,
I see both sides as completely
ridiculous.
Both of both of them grounded in
complete absurdity is they're just
different.
Yeah.
But nobody knows why they're deciding
that the real reasons that people make
decisions are fear,
identity.
Um,
you know,
they have some aspiration.
They've,
they've got something they're trying to
solve.
There's something to try to work out.
But the reasons we give are usually
completely false.
And the,
the grounding for this
is that if you think about evolution,
I assume you believe we evolved.
Yes.
Um,
there was no requirement in evolution
that we ever understand our environment
the way we imagine that we do.
And here's an example of that.
You could believe that you are a monk.
You know,
you're reincarnated from the 10th
century monk like Steven Seagal.
It does.
He believe that he's like a buddha or
something from an actual,
like he actually got it bestowed upon
him by some Tibetan character.
All right,
so let's use Steven Seagal.
So Steven Seagal can be standing in a
grocery store next to,
let's say a Muslim who believes that his
profit literally flew to heaven on a
winged horse.
Those two people don't live the same
reality,
but they both buy groceries.
They both go,
they cook it,
they live,
they survive.
So it turns out that understanding the
reality at an actual,
you know,
I really know what his objective Lee
happening and I get it and I've got a
mental model that's quite accurate.
We don't need any of that.
So it would be deeply unlikely that we
evolved such a specific skill that's
completely unnecessary as far as we can
tell.
You know,
we do need to know that if I,
if you run into this wall,
you know your hand is going to hurt.
So there's some basic stuff,
but we're probably all in even
interpreting that experience
differently.
So there's no reason to think that the
way I think of it as the way you think
of it.
So I see the world is this big
irrational ball and I use the hypnotist
persuader skills to back up and try to
deduce,
you know,
what's really driving things.
And when people said I was a trump
supporter,
what they meant was,
um,
they may have only seen part of what I
was talking about.
I was writing about his skill as a
persuader.
And what I mean is that I noticed in him
the skills that I've developed over
decades for persuasion,
but I had a higher level than I've ever
seen.
Meaning that he is the most persuasive
living human I've ever experienced.
And I mean that in terms of,
uh,
actual technique,
you know,
he's,
he's full of technique and it's all the
time.
I'll give it,
give you some examples of that.
First Time I noticed it was the very
first debate when Megan Kelly was asking
him the question about the insults he
had allegedly said to women,
not allegedly,
he said them.
And this is a setup that any other
politician with his set up is totally
trapped because they can either try to
like deny they sat at and then somebody
has a videotape and that doesn't work.
Or they can say,
oh,
I didn't mean it.
There's almost nothing you can say.
You're just trapped.
And that would have been the end of his
campaign.
The first debate should have been over.
And if you remember,
do you remember what he said?
No,
I don't.
She said,
you said this,
this and this about women.
And he smiled.
He sort of looked at the audience it
looked like or the camera and he said
only Rosie O'donnell and the audience,
he rubbed it.
And laughter.
Completely unexpected and a place
inappropriate.
Provocative.
And,
and what I noticed was the Rosie
O'donnell is that is a visual image that
everybody shares,
right?
You've got a picture of her.
So,
as I say the name and for his base that
he was catering to,
it was an unpopular image and one that
would just suck all the energy away from
the question,
which was toxic.
And really,
you know,
you can't touch the question.
You just have to suck all the energy
into another part of the room and wait
for the time to run out.
And that's what he did.
And it became the headline,
blah,
blah.
And He,
you know,
it's certainly a highlighted the things
he said about women,
maybe more than it would have,
but the way he escaped that got my
attention.
And I thought,
that doesn't look normal.
All right.
That,
that's,
uh,
that's operating at another level.
And so I looked for more examples of it
and you could see it everywhere and it
was especially clear by the time he
started saying,
um,
uh,
well,
the other visual things he does is he
says,
build a wall.
And you can just imagine a wall when he
says,
uh,
we're,
we're paying too much ransom to a ran
for those soldiers.
He says,
we paid,
you know,
400 million or whatever the number is.
He goes,
imagine that money piled up.
It'd be so much money you would fill
this room.
You can't even imagine that big pile of
money.
You always goes for the visual because
we know that the,
the visual part of our Brayden's the
dominant part,
and if you can get its attention and get
it on your message,
it talks the rest of your brain and to
anything you want it to.
Um,
when he talks about Isis,
he goes visual also.
He doesn't say they are bad people who's
religions you know,
has been distorted to the type of thing
you might hear from Hillary Clinton.
He says they put you in cages and they
train you in the cage.
They chop your head off.
I mean,
you can see that you're playing in your
head.
So everything he does gets more
attention than everything everybody else
does because he puts it into a
provocative picture.
So that was the first thing I noticed.
Then when he got to Jeb Bush and he
needed to defeat jab because he was the
strongest competitor.
So if he couldn't get past him,
there was no point and he wouldn't have
to have a strong,
and he went after him fast and he went
after him with the low energy kill shot.
That's why I call these linguistic kill
shots.
It's not just an insult,
it's not just a clever nickname.
And we saw Clinton tried to come up with
clever nicknames that had no,
no,
no purchase whatsoever,
like dangerous Donald.
You know,
it just didn't work.
But look at the,
look at low Energy Jeb.
Here's how it's engineered.
It's engineered for confirmation bias,
meaning that want the future to make
this look like a better nickname every
day.
And you want it to match his
physicality.
So before I ever heard low energy Jeb,
I had a good impression of Jeb Bush.
I thought when you looked at Jeb Bush,
didn't you say to yourself,
this guy,
it looks like a cool character.
Like if,
if,
no,
but he looked like he was an in control.
Um,
calm,
reasonable.
Exactly.
The person you'd want.
If the,
if the nuclear,
you know,
question came up.
If there was some big decision Jeb Bush
isn't going to get excited about it.
Seems like a competent CEO competency.
Oh,
exactly.
And as soon as trump said low energy,
could you see him?
And the other way he was low energy and
he will always be low energy.
Lying Ted,
lying Ted Lying Ted was beautiful and
tag.
Cause you knew that because he's a
politician,
sometime in the next several months he's
going to say stuff that you can say is a
lie.
Whether it is or not,
it doesn't have to.
But more importantly,
uh,
ted has a,
a physicality about him.
The unfortunately he's got beady eyes.
And I've said this before,
is if you're going to cast a movie,
so we need a guy who's looks dishonest,
right?
It would be his face.
Unfortunately.
I mean,
I don't know if he's actually dishonest.
I'm not going to make the judgment.
So came up with the Zodiac killer thing.
Was that a trump fan or was it trump
himself that started saying that Ted was
the Zodiac killer.
Uh,
I think that probably started with the
fan.
But,
so the other thing that was fucking
harsh,
man,
he be given speeches.
Are you the Zodiac killer?
People would scream it out,
like imagine having to deal with that.
And did your father kill you know
somebody?
Yeah.
His father was,
maybe it's dad was the Zodiac killer.
Is that what the,
cause the Zodiac killer.
It was like the 70s,
right?
Not Be old enough.
Uh,
so crooked Hillary,
crooked Hillary,
same thing.
Sarah Aliens,
a brilliant ones.
So she wasn't physically,
you know,
as limber as a young person.
So you could imagine her sort of a
little bit crooked physically.
And you knew that there would be stories
coming out in which people could say,
well,
there's another example of that.
Crookedness did you see?
But you thought that in a physical
sense,
like the way she looked,
all I thought about as corruption,
I heard Crooked Hillary.
I saw her like with like a burglar's
mask on trying to sneak away with bags
that had dollar signs on them.
Yeah.
That's what I saw.
If you look at any one of these
individually has nicknames,
you could say,
well it's sort of random.
He just got lucky.
But if you look at them all,
they all have that physicality.
They all have the uh,
the priming so that you know,
you'll confirmation bias will kick in
whatever you see after that we'll just
fit the label because it's the first
thing you think,
well he's a performer,
you know,
you,
you can say Donald Trump is a
businessman.
He most certainly is.
It most certainly is a real estate
investor,
but he's been a public figure for
decades.
And when you're a public figure,
you're a performer.
He's performing all the time and he's
also,
he
likes to win.
And so when he's engaging in people,
he makes it personal.
So he's gotten very good at what's
called playing the dozens.
I know playing the dozens is tell us
it's a insult thing.
You know,
like you can like one guy like guys in
the,
the hood in the inner cities.
I started out as a black term,
but it's essentially like a version of a
your mama contest.
Like,
some guys are way better at your mama
jokes.
They're way better at playing.
The dozens are way better at shitting on
other people around them.
And it's for the entertainment of each
other.
So a huge thing amongst comedians,
we shit on each other constantly left
and right,
but it's generally encouraged and we all
enjoy it,
you know?
But when a guy has decades and decades
and decades of this like Donald Trump,
but a very high level because he's known
to be a billionaire investor who puts
his name on everything,
everything and still win big at which I
talk about developing systems for
succeeding,
one of the systems is to,
um,
and you do this too,
stack together what I would call
ordinary skills until your stack is
different than anybody else's.
So in my case,
I'm not a great artist.
Uh,
you know,
I didn't take any writing writing
courses,
but I'm pretty good at drawing and I'm
pretty good at writing and up,
a little bit of funny.
So I put them together and I couldn't do
a comic strip because it's rare that you
get somebody who's,
let's say in the top 10% of three
different things,
but it's not hard to be in the top 10%
of the things if you're,
if you're going after them.
So if you look at trump,
he wrote a book on negotiating.
So he knows business,
he knows negotiating,
he knows public speaking.
He has a sense of humor,
a really good one.
He's quick on his feet now.
He knows politics,
you know,
from both the inside and the outside.
Um,
he knows twitter.
If,
you know,
I could probably go on and you would
say,
if you looked at any one of those
things,
he's not the best you've ever seen.
You know,
he's not the best public speaker,
the funniest person,
etc. But there aren't many people who
can do all of those things in the top
10%.
But as a public speaker,
I don't think he's nearly in the top 10%
I think he's a,
I mean,
I'm just being honest.
I think he has a very poor efficiency of
of words like,
um,
he uses,
he repeats himself when it's not really
important and when we repeats itself,
what I usually see is like someone's
searching for the next thing to say,
you know what I'm saying?
Like he'll say,
you know,
I'm going to be honest with you,
I'm going to be honest with you.
Okay,
I'm going to be honest with you here.
It,
he'll do that in a way that is not,
it's not efficient,
not efficient,
but it's persuasive and that's why it
does sometimes.
But it also no repetition.
Repetition sometimes.
Sometimes.
And sometimes it's clunky.
Yeah.
I feel like he,
I feel like there's a lot of times where
it's his style to do that and he's done
it before.
But even like in delivering lines,
you've got to know when did not talk.
Like here's birth example when he said
that he called the president of the
president of Mexico up and they had the
conversation about the wall and he said,
the wall just got 10 foot higher.
He's like,
yeah,
that's what I said.
That is what I said.
Like he repeats that said he should've
just let it hang.
He should've been said,
the wall just got 10 foot higher.
They would have went crazy and he got to
walk back and forth and just sucked it
in.
But he kept talking.
See,
that's not the best speaker like Obama,
I feel is a way better public speaker.
Way more efficient with his words,
way better control of the sentences that
he speaks.
But it's more professional.
I think you're judging on
a standard that I probably wouldn't use.
So I took the Dale Carnegie course
teaching you how to be a public speaker
and their course taught you zero
technique.
It was a,
of course on public speaking in which
they taught you nothing about technique.
The things that you're saying he's doing
right,
not necessarily technique.
What,
let me just finish this off shore.
I'm sorry.
What?
They taught you
confidence and,
and if you were happy and confident,
you would almost always do well,
even if you make a mistake,
you just correct.
So he strikes me as the confident Dale
Carnegie type of Speaker,
the person who's,
who's selling an emotion.
It's an experience.
You're not going there really to get
information.
It's not really,
you know,
well crafted jokes you're looking for,
you're going there to feel something and
you can't,
you can't deny that 30,000 people in a
stadium with red hats on,
you know,
they were feeling something.
So in terms of delivering and emotion,
top 10%.
Hmm.
Interesting.
Um,
well I think that for absolutely one
thing you could say is he knows how to
do the Donald Trump thing and the Donald
Trump thing is very different than the
rest of the politicians thing.
Right?
The Donald Trump thing is not humble.
The Donald Trump thing,
we'll tell you about his past successes
and use them to tell you how he's going
to be successful in the future.
The Donald Trump thing,
when confronted with certain things,
like the thing about it,
you know him saying something about
Hillary lacking stamina and then you,
it goes off about having a winning
temperament.
I have a winning temperament.
There's not a lot of people who could do
that in that sort of a political form.
Like if if,
say Mitt Romney was running for
president,
he started saying,
I have a winning temperament.
I,
they'd be like,
oh,
it's gone fucking crazy.
Right.
You remember how Howard Dean got knocked
out of the race just for screaming?
He just screamed at a rally and it was
over.
The wind came out of the balloon.
But you know,
you know what Howard Dean did wrong,
what?
He always screamed once.
It's all,
it's all about contrast.
Well,
he also didn't make fun of it.
You know,
he should have come on and he should
have done something to make fun of it.
He should have had a speech where he
talked about,
so I got a little carried away folks.
You know,
like he,
he,
he hid from it.
It feels like he could have fixed that.
Yes.
Yeah,
I had that at the time.
Well,
if the problem was it was contrary to
what he was selling,
he was selling this buttoned up package
deal.
And in the middle of that package deal
is a fucking pro wrestling fans
screaming from a Suplex,
you know,
like Hulk Hogan Suplex is the iron
sheik.
And I mean that's what it was like.
I mean,
that's not the guy who you want to have
the button.
So if you heard the studies,
uh,
I think this has been replicated,
it fairly reliable that if you want to
addict somebody to something,
let's say this year,
your Shell,
um,
if you gave them a really good product
every time,
it actually wouldn't be as addictive as
if once in a while it wasn't good and
they had to sorta like wait and
anticipate.
Oh,
there's that good one again.
Right?
So,
uh,
unpredictable rewards are far more
addicting,
unpredictable.
So,
uh,
Hillary Clinton who reward you every
time,
but it's just about the same is not
going to be nearly as addicting as
Donald Trump.
Who disappoints the fuck out of you.
You're like,
God,
I was just starting to like you.
Why did you say that that way?
Right?
And then two weeks later he comes out
with something,
you say,
Shit,
I love you again.
And you know,
so it's,
he's got that addictive pattern going.
Well I'll tell you what,
once all that grab the pussy stuff got
out of the way.
Um,
he was doing a lot of speeches and the
rundown the last few days and I watched
a few of them on television because I,
I've almost felt like even though I knew
I was going to vote,
almost felt like some sort of a
spectator like this is,
this cannot possibly be real to speak to
your software simulation idea in the
beginning that a lot of people share.
By the way,
this is not just crazy Scott Adams and
me,
but there's a lot of folks out there
that think that we're living in a
simulation.
Right?
But as he would give these speeches and
there was some of his speeches he gave
where there was these moments,
are you like,
if someone could tell that guy to keep
it at seven,
like where he's at right there and talk
like that always and avoid all the crazy
shit.
But man,
the crazy shit is what you get.
Like that's,
that's the thing about people like trump
or like any powerful super dominator
type character like that.
Uh,
you don't have some flaws.
Lot of them.
Look what he kept saying all the time.
He was always saying he was the energy
guy yesterday.
I look at my crowds.
The other one has no stamina.
This one's,
you know,
low energy.
Um,
he knew the facts didn't matter.
He knew the policy didn't matter.
And by the end,
I think everybody agrees they didn't,
I mean,
by,
by election day,
a lot of people were saying,
well,
I sure like that.
TPP standards.
Hmm.
Method.
Like that was happening.
There was no issues,
no issues.
It just,
it just came down to which one you
hated.
The more
[inaudible].